L
>> OURNKTOPLTG REPORT.ERNG THAE.
G ILD GEWE CLARK.NESO
TIODRAE
YIY DEFENSMIN LIRACTRUSS TLATET
GREAT TAIC OF TH
IS FM OVEYE , VERY RSE
EXPECTATIONS.
TS LOTS MOREPOO COME ILP UKRAIN
THE IN T
NOW,HAN ISAS YOU CAN S FM THE M
IP'S GOING TO BE THE NEXT OBCTDN
AV
DENDCITIES.
EY
THEY NEED BILE ARTILRYD NITIONRT
IT'S GOTME FROM OUALLIESSTERN E.
E UKRANSLY
HAVE TO PREPARE FOR WHAT
YOG HE HE SIDE LINESANTHIS
TH WIN THI WANT TO WT E RUSSIANS
OUT,S THE THING.FTER CAMPAIGN
THE LAST 50 ARS, 70 ARITED SS DL
COUNLDIERSION
JUST AS GOOUEY
AS WE ARE.
E THEMEY4 UR
PLUS THEY KNOWRAIN.
NEED AIRCRAFT. THE WT EMIPNTD. S
THEY NEED COTHOSFOEHOW WE' TE
EMEYD.SUPPORT.
D T,GOTOE AIRC>> S
TH
THISY MAY?
HE WANTS UKRAINE THE BC ATES.ACD
OEUPEO SHATTER NATOD HE
WANTS THE IT
THIS IS FOR E MARBLES.RYGHNOLL.
TO WESTERN
REFO.
HE'DIK H
K S.IONALL
SO HE WANT DISRUPT L SYSTEM.
ICHINA CHINA IS ON THE SIDE MAS
T WAY TOAY TTE GE  T
RUSSIA ON THIS BATTLEFIELD.
>> GENERAL, VEWEE WILL WIND UPIN
SHE GOMALYO CIDED  BATTLEFIELD
DE ON WHAT HAPPEEL
KTH RUSSIA AN
UKRAINE TO LLG ASSISTANCE TO UK
RAIN DASHING, NDING RMINAINIANS
ZELENSKYY KNOWS HE HAS TO BE A
BECAUSE IES PECTO.
RM ITALYCE
SU IOE GBACKO BUSIFULLY  REALLYA
HE AS
USUAL.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE KEPT O
D  WAYHR
HANDLE RUSSIA  ON TH
GROUND.
COIS, PLEASE, LEPS OUT OF
RASAFELY.
YOU CACO
O
SH NG
EY
>>> UKRAINE SAOR
E THROUG
HUMANITARIAN OBUT WITH RUSSIAN B
E SINGS, FOR
EVERYONE.OF CHOSE
DESPERATELIN
POPULAR SINGWMGE T
VIE MESSAGE.
>> SMILE.r: THIS CHURCH IN THE Y
MEHO WTOOCCUPI Y.
VOLUNTRI PEACE BUTOT
JUST WANT O A MECHANACETIME NOW
FAMILY, BRING US CLOR.
S
LIKE A T O OUT.INPROACHES MARKE.
RUSSIAN CONTROL.T ITRIDOR NEGOTD
BY THETHE ARRANGEMENT WHEREBPEOT
SIMPLE.
EVERYTHING IS REOOD AND CIGAESRA